alors sa mère avait embauché un ouvrier
quoi puis alors je travaille et il a vu
m'animait coup de circuit le disais il
avait une manière de 10h à ce mot
presque prêt qui bricoler une fronde
d'une bombe utilisée alors algos celui
là très bien ça alors un jour il était
devant sa porte et puis lee bricoler
avec siri joie quoi alors il se
maintient nous didier l'outil du riz
alors la mer latin à lydia tantôt elle
te vendre et si nous avons essuyé de
nouveaux talents de culotte sur le même
banc courrier où il était très gai
jovial et une pensée souvent car faire
des farces à l'instituteur au curé tout
ça je crois qu'il n'a jamais oublié ce
village natal ah non non non il est
chaque année même quand le week-end
quand tu pouvais venir se détendre ici
il le faisait à chaque fois que c'était
possible que ces distractions préférés
ici
les distractions préférées voyez vous
c'était surtout de
respirer un peu la nature quand ils
venaient ici tout le monde était heureux
de le voir on s'inquiétait de son avenir
professionnel ce qui était pourtant
l'avenir puisqu'ils étaient assurés
enfin on se renseigne avant lui demander
des choses il y en avait qui
représentait avait utilisé alors ayons
andré fais-tu toujours le gymnase à
paris tout un tas de petites blagues lui
ils se prêtaient volontiers la chaussée
de raconter des petites histoires ygrié
il savait créer un climat de détente
[Applaudissements]
ça a quand même duré un certain moment
jusqu'au jour où il est venu s'installer
un malheureux terre d'ici avec un fils
qui jouait du bonjour ou bourvil a
certainement fait tout de suite
connaissance avec ce jeune homme puisque
ça ne l'intéressait alors à ce moment-là
les formes les brûler les parcs tomber
enfin ça n'allait plus il était très
gentil back parfait pour être dans le
pétrin il a bien fait sa sortie il est
recruté dans toute la région
parce que tu étais très sympathique et
était trop cher du tout il parlait à
tout le monde tous les gens qu'il
rencontrait et cher et la main tout
il avait un bon apport touche était très
très sympathique très connu dans la
région
[Musique]